so if you've gotten this far I been
waiting for several videos to get to the
optimal line that minimizes the squared
distance to all of those points so let's
just get to the punchline let's solve
for the optimal M and B and just based
on what we did in the last videos
there's two way to do that we actually
now know two points that lie on that
line so we can literally find the slope
of that line and then the y intercept
the B there
or we could just say it's a solution to
this system of equations and they're
actually mathematically equivalent so
let's solve for M first and if we want
to solve for M we want to cancel out the
B so let me rewrite this top equation
just the way it's written over here so
we have M times the mean of the X
Squared's plus B times the mean of X we
could even do it let's we can even do it
better than that one step better than
that is to actually we based on the work
we did in the last video we can just
subtract this bottom equation from this
top equation so let me subtract it or
let's add the negative so if I make this
negative this is negative this is
negative what do we get what do we get
we get M we get M times the mean of the
X's minus the mean of the X Squared's
over the mean of x over the mean of the
X's the plus B and the negative B cancel
out is equal to is equal to the mean of
the Y's minus the mean of the X Y's over
the mean of the X's and then we can
divide both sides of the equation by
this and so we get M M is equal to the
mean of the Y's the mean of the Y's
minus the mean of the X Y's over the
mean of the X's over this the mean of
the X is minus the mean of the X
Squared's over the mean of the X's now
notice this is the exact same thing that
you would get if you found the slope
between these two points over here
change in Y so the difference between
that Y and that Y is that right over
there over the change in X is the change
in that X that X minus that X is exactly
this over here now to simplify it we can
multiply
the numerator and the denominator by the
mean and X the mean of the X's and I do
that just so we don't have this in the
denominator both places and so if we
multiply the numerator by the mean of
the X's we get the mean of the X's times
the mean of the Y's times the mean of
the Y's minus this and this will cancel
out meet minus the mean of the x wise
minus the mean of the X wise all of that
over mean of the XS times the mean of
the XS is just going to be the mean of
the X's squared the mean of the X is
squared minus minus over here you have
over here you have the mean of the x
squared and that's what we get for em
that's what we get for em and then if we
want to solve for B if we want to solve
for B we literally can just substitute
back we literally can just substitute
back into either equation but this
equation right here is simpler and so if
we wanted to solve for B there we can
solve for B in terms of M we just
subtract M times the mean of X's from
both sides we get the mean let me write
it this way we get B is equal to the
mean of the Y's the mean of the Y's
minus M times the mean of the X's so
what you do is you take your data point
you find the mean of the X is the mean
of the Y's the mean of the X wise the
mean of the X is squared you find your M
once you find your M then you can
substitute back in here and you find
your B and then you have your actual
optimal line and we're done so these are
the two big formula takeaways for our
optimal line what I'm going to do in the
next video and this is where you can
kind of if anyone was skipping up to
this point the next video is where they
should reengage because we're actually
going to use these formulas we're going
to use these formulas for the best
fitting line at least when you measure
the error by the squared distances from
the points we're going to use these
formulas to actually find the best line
for some data